VOICE OVER: If you’ve turned on a light
outside at night, you’ve probably seen this.
SAMUEL FABIAN: As soon as humans started
lighting fires or creating light at night,
they noticed that seemingly suicidally
insects would dive into them or kind of
emerge out the night and cluster around
these light sources, and we wondered why.
VO: Previous explanations have included
insects using the moon to navigate,
or simply being drawn to the heat
given off by incandescent bulbs.
Now though advances in camera technology are
allowing researchers to study the flight of
these insects in more detail than ever before,
and this group have made a key discovery.
Flying insects seem to be twisting to
keep their back to the light. Rather
than being attracted towards it, they find
themselves stuck in a loop flying around it.
Have these experiments finally answered the
question - what draws the moth to the flame?
VO: Moths' attraction to light is well known
enough to have inspired a commonly used phrase,
but it’s not just moths that are
attracted to artificial lights.
SAM: If you're stood by a light at night,
and you see something batting around,
it's probably not just moths, there are
flies, there are wasps, there's any number
of different insects. Basically any insect
that can fly, more or less, is going to end
up at lights at night. It just so happens that
a whole bunch of insects rarely fly at night,
and so an example of that would be the dragonfly,
we we we tend not to think about dragonflies
coming lights at night, but actually it
turns out if you get a dragonfly to fly,
at night, it ends up circling around
the light just like your moth does.
VO: And even though this behaviour is very
common, explaining it has proven tricky.
SAM: The real problem is that insects move
really fast for their body size. So when you
film it turns out as a little blur even under
quite bright light and then you take that at
night where you have to use infrared lights in
order to illuminate the insect but not have it
see the light, it's only been recently that we've
had sensitive enough cameras to allow us to film
insects at night, at speeds that then allow us to
see what the insect is actually doing in the air.
VO: The team attach reflective markers to the
insects’ bodies. Then, eight motion capture
cameras allow them to track its exact position
and orientation at 200 frames per second.
SAM: The camera can detect these
little markers on the backs of
the insect and we can get a really
accurate read on exactly where it is
in space and actually we can tell
the orientation in space as well.
VO: As well as this lab data, the
team made observations in the wild,
under more natural conditions.
SAM: Either in our back gardens filming things
or traveling down to Costa Rica in order to film
large numbers of different kinds of night
flying insect around light sources. That's
where we're using high frame rate cameras under
kind of constant infrared illumination to record
insects traveling around light sources
and that come to light sources at night.
VO: Together these data revealed exactly what
was happening as the insects
approached a light source.
SAM: What we kept finding is that
insects such as dragonflies, moths,
butterflies and other night flying insects as
well, were tilting their backs - uh which we
call the dorsal axis - their dorsum towards
the light. And this matches onto a response
we've known about for quite some time in fact,
it's been written about in the literature for
probably about the last 100 years, and
that's called a dorsal light response.
VO: This so called dorsal light response has
been described for some time in insects and fish,
and is believed to be used to help them
orient themselves when moving in 3D space.
SAM: It's quite strange for us to think
about this because as animals that spend
most of our time on the ground it's quite
obvious which way gravity is, but actually
if you're flying you're pulling all kinds of
g-forces and those g-forces or accelerations
as you're moving around can kind of mask exactly
where true gravity is especially if there's some
sort of big aerial turbulence that hits you, you
want to very quickly work out which way is up.
VO: And before humans and
their lightbulbs came along,
looking for the relative brightness of the
sky compared to the earth was a good way of
finding up. So insects tilt their backs
towards the brightest area they can see.
SAM: That means that all of their
flight forces they're producing,
the lift is they're not pointing in the
right direction for them to continue flight,
they're going to start curving. And so that's why
we see them circling, and not really spiralling
in, cruising around and round and round and
seeming completely stuck and unable to leave.
VO: And this isn’t the only problem this
simple reflex causes insects around lights.
SAM: If we give them light from beneath we
actually see that insects totally invert
themselves and flip upside down, and that
obviously is not a good way to get about at
night because they then crash straight on into
the ground, and that's probably why if you have
light shining on a kind of patch of floor you
tend to get insects sort of plummeting out of
the darkness straight onto that floor. They flip
themselves upside down and crashed, and we also
get stalling which is where insects that are
flying away from the light begin to pitch up,
pitch up, and they're then at not producing
enough flight force to maintain the climb that
they're attempting to do and that causes them
to slow down and tip onto new flight courses.
VO: Other explanations for this behaviour
that have been put forward over the years
don’t seem to match the new
observations.. The insects in
this study weren’t attracted to heat -
nor were they keeping the lights at the
same angle relative to their body as they
would if trying to navigate by the moon.
So is this case closed for the
mystery of the mesmerizing effect
of artificial light on flying insects? Not quite…
SAM: There are several species of night flying
insects that we don't find at light traps and
I really want to get hold of those because I want
to see whether or not they still have this dorsal
light response. Because if they're not using
light particularly to work out which way is
up and we know that they're flying near lights
but don't ever seem to get entrapped that's a
very strong link to draw that it is really this
behavioral phenomenon that leads to all of these
insects coming to light at night, because we
cannot yet say absolutely this is the only
influence of the light on the insect while it's
flying around there may be additional factors.
VO: This study only looked at insect
behaviour within a few metres of a
light source, but what happens
when insects are further away.
SAM: We'd like to ecologically contextualize
this behavior of coming to light and determine
exactly what the kind of capture radius around
a light source would be at night and how it
affects insects that are doing different tasks
around an ecosystem. So whether that be foraging
over flowers or whether that be migrating
at high altitude directly over overhead.
VO: And understanding this mechanism doesn’t
just answer an age-old question - it could
lead to new ways to preserve and
protect these flying insects.
SAM: How could we change lighting environments
to not trap insects because we're facing a
massive decline in insects around the world
and artificial light at night is one of the
factors that could potentially be leading to
this decline. So only through understanding
the actual mechanism that causes insects
to get trapped around light can we begin
to understand how we could prevent them
getting trapped around light sources.